Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in
as we are in the day of Jum on Jum.
We usually read
in the portion of regarding the virtues
and merits of the day of Jum. This is
chapter 210 from
regarding the merits of the day of Jum.
[Silence]
Ramadan.
Hadith number
on the authority of Abi
who narrates that the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
said,
"The five daily prayers
and one J to the next and one Ramadan to
the next
act as an expeation
for what is between them of sin,
provided major sins are avoided.
[Silence]
He then
So here we have a condition. The prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam placed
the condition is that these great acts
of worship
five daily prayers
Ramadan
fasting Ramadan and
Juma
that they act as an expeation of sin
provided under the condition
that major sins
are avoided. Major sins are refrained
from.
And so
because of the way that the narration is
structured,
the majority of the scholars of Islam
have explained this narration and other
narrations it, other narrations
similar to this with the same theme.
as being an expeation for minor sins.
As being an expeation for minor sins.
Why? Why minor sins? Why are they not an
expeation for major sins?
Number one, major sins are forgiven by
way of repentance.
A person has to repent from them.
Number two,
major sins
are what invalidates
the action of these ma of these major
acts of worship. Meaning if a person
engages in major sin,
these acts of worship do not act as an
expeation
of sin.
And so to say that a person is
simultaneously committing major sin and
refraining from major sin, this is
impossible. The person is either
committing major sin or not.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam tells us here
that these acts of worship, the five
daily prayers,
one Ramadan to a next, one to a next,
they act as an expeation. If a person
provided a person refrains from major
sin,
the act of refraining
is a type of worship.
What is the reward of one who refrains
is that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
forgives for him his sin.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
that which translates to and if you all
refrain from the major sins or
prohibitions written upon you, we will
in return
expedate and forgive you your remaining
sin.
And so the real big question here is
what is major sin?
What is minor sin?
Wasam
[Silence]
Jam.
And so the real question is what is a
major sin?
Because if we are able to identify a
major sin, we can then understand what a
minor sin is.
We know from the Quran that sins are
categorized
into two categories.
In this respect, in this regard,
major and minor.
Minor does not mean that they are
something to scoff at or thumb one's
nose at. A sin is a sin. It is a
disobedience against the creator.
However,
it is minor
contrasted to its major counterpart.
This is why this wording is used.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
that
that those who are guaranteed
forgiveness are those who refrain from
major
sin and
indecency. major sin and
wrongdoing except for those minor
infractions.
We even have this in law. Where has law
gotten this from? It has gotten this
from the law of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala throughout the millennia
that even here in this country
from a judicial standpoint
that
crime is
described as being that which is a
misdemeanor
and that which is a felony.
and felony.
In Islamic law, it is major and minor.
So the question is again, what is a
major sin?
Major sin has been debated amongst the
scholars of Islam. It has even been
debated amongst the companions.
However,
the most settled upon
opinion
is the opinion of Ib
and that is
that major sin is any sin that has a
particular
punishment.
attached to it.
Any sin that has a particular punishment
[Silence]
And so every sin that has a particular
punishment, what does that mean? It's
not just generally prohibited. It has a
particular punishment either in this
life or the hereafter
in this life such as some kind of
violence against its perpetrator,
some kind of physical punishment
such as execution or stoning or cutting
or what have you, or a monetary
punishment such as the one who withholds
zakia.
They are to be fought against until they
concede and then half of their wealth is
to be taken as punishment.
Right? Etc. In the case of a zena,
fornication, that the person is to be
living elsewhere out of his
out of his city, out of his native land
for a year or a person gets a particular
title
such as this person is considered a fess
if they do it. This person is considered
un untrustworthy if they do it. for
instance,
meaning those who accuse
innocent people.
They have a particular punishment with
Allah. They're referred to as a
f
or
there is a particular punishment in the
hereafter such as Allah will not look at
them nor speak to them on the day of
judgment nor purify them of their sin
etc. So any
sin, any prohibition that when it is
done its doer earns himself a particular
punishment, this is considered a major
sin.
Anything that does not meet this
criteria is considered a minor sin. So
one of the virtues of the day of Ju is
that a person who refrains from these
major sins one to the next acts as an
expeation of all sin between them.
Alhamdulillah.